it was one of the Whittier occupants of
the Oval Office President John F Kennedy
once said that a committee was fell
people doing the work of one it's my
good fortune to know one person who does
the work of 12 I would like to say that
she is widely admired all over the world
she's a great beauty she's a great
actress and she's a great humanitarian
my friend is the former Academy Award
winner and she spends her time now
traveling the globe with untiring
efforts to help feed and clothe and
educate and give medical care to
hopeless and helpless children all over
the world I might add she's also the
woman in whose honor the word elegant
was first coined how fortunate you are
and how fortunate I am to present to you
this evening miss Audrey Hepburn
this year the Academy Board of Governors
has voted to award an honorary Oscar to
the great Indian filmmaker Satyajit Rai
mr. Rai has been making films for almost
four decades the Academy recognizes mr.
rice rare mastery of the art of motion
pictures and of his profound humanism
which has had an indelible influence on
filmmakers and audiences throughout the
world he has said that he aims to
capture both what is unique in the
Indian experience and that which is
universal
unfortunately mr. Rai is not well and
cannot be with us tonight but he is able
to speak with us from his hospital room
in Calcutta well that's when eccentric
sort of experience for me to be here
tonight to receive this magnificent
award certainly the best achievement of
my moviemaking career by the smart Walsh
school why I was terribly interested in
the cinema became a film fan wrote to
Deanna Devon got a reply was delighted
go to Ginger Rogers didn't get a reply
then of course I got interested into
cinema as an artful and I wrote a
trilogy letter to Billy Wilder
after seeing double indemnity he didn't
apply either well they were but I have
learnt everything I've learned about the
craft of cinema from the making of
American films I've been watching
American films very carefully over the
years and I love them for what they
entertain and then later loved them for
the what they thought so I expressed my
gratitude to the American cinema toward
the Motion Picture Association who give
me this award and who made me Pro so
proud thank you very very much
a tune for Michael bukka's Kevin Costner
more
and music
you